Henry Cavill had to choose between a super-powerful
metahuman who fights for justice and one that
fights for coin.
Now, fans have opinions…and conspiracies
about the choice.
Arguably Henry Cavill's two most iconic roles
— Superman from the DC Universe, and Geralt
of Rivia from "The Witcher" — have simultaneously
found their way back into the social spotlight,
for very different reasons.
In the weeks leading up to the release of
"Black Adam," Dwayne "The Rock" Johnson's
antihero passion project, it was revealed,
by The Rock himself that Superman would make
a guest appearance.
As the role had been absent from a slew of
recent DC projects, and because Cavill remained
silent about his status as a member of the
DCEU, the general population assumed that
he was done with DC.
Now, however, it's been confirmed by Cavill
himself on Instagram that he will be returning
to the DC Universe for more Superman-centric
content.
Almost immediately after that news dropped,
it was revealed that Netflix had hired Liam
Hemsworth to take over the role of Geralt
of Rivia for "The Witcher," starting with
the newly confirmed fourth season.
Because of the timing, these two pieces of
information feel connected, as if Warner Bros.
would require all of Cavill's time moving
forward and he had to choose between the two roles.
That feels logical, but there's another potential
theory behind Cavill's departure, and it looks
to carry some weight.
Fans took to Twitter to share their view on
the situation, as the idea of Henry Cavill
leaving "The Witcher" just to give DC his
entire focus didn't align with his previous
statements on the subject.
For context, in a 2021 interview with "The
Hollywood Reporter," Cavill promised his ongoing
commitment to the series, provided that the
content remained faithful to the source material.
Specifically, the outlet wrote,
"The actor remains committed to supporting
Hissrich's vision to keep 'The Witcher' going
for at least seven seasons.
'Absolutely,' Cavill says.
'As long as we can keep telling great stories
which honor [author Andrzej] Sapkowski's work.'"
With that in mind, one Twitter user tweeted,
"I like how everyone thinks Henry Cavill left
because [the] Superman role paid more.
But there's info out there confirming that
a lot of people working on The Witcher hated
the source material and the games.
Henry probably didn't want to continue his
contract and work with them."
That information can be found in articles
where it's revealed that Beau DeMayo, a previous
producer for "The Witcher," claimed the writers
for the Netflix series actively despised both
Andrzej Sapkowski's books and CD Projekt Red's
games.
If this were to be proven true, then it would
explain why Cavill continued to do interviews,
where he suggests he would love for subsequent
seasons to stay loyal to the books.
This could mean that Cavill would have left
"The Witcher" with or without the safety net
of more DC projects coming down the pipeline.
"Evil is evil, Stregabor.
Lesser, greater, middling, it's all the same."
While it has yet to be officially confirmed
if the writers chose to scorn the source material,
more and more fans are latching onto the narrative.
One tweet said,
"I'm upset that Henry Cavill is leaving The
Witcher, but I'm even more upset at the audacity
of the Netflix writers in thinking they can
do better than Sapkowski's novels (especially
after season 2 proved that they, in fact,
cannot)."
While another tweet declared,
" ... this show is done; season 2 was pretty
bad so makes sense that Henry Cavill left
... he said he wanted Netflix to be true to
the source material."
No one seems to harbor animosity towards Liam
Hemsworth for joining the cast, but most fans
have stated that they can't even fathom another
actor in the role.
Polite indifference to Hemsworth's resume
boost doesn't necessarily equate to viewers
for Netflix.
If social media is any indicator of the future
of the series, "The Witcher" is likely to
see a significant drop in streams from the
third season to the fourth.
In fairness to all involved, the future of
the DC Universe is still on shaky ground,
too, but that's another story.